- If you ask me name one core
reason suicide rates are up,
we didn't pay the price in 2009.
I'm just a believer in checks and balances
and because we have massive
entitlement and overcoddling
predicated on not having
the proper adversity
based on our actions.
(upbeat music)
- [Jon] Do you have your tag?
- Literally before every video,
before every single vide
now that I'm gonna put out,
- [Male] Gary Vee, Vee, Vee, Vee.
- [Jon] That's not what I
thought you were gonna go with.
- I mean that may not be it,
we're still playing.
What were you thinking it
was gonna be, more my voice?
- [Jordan] Yeah I thought it was gonna be
like yeah something like that.
- I still don't know what to do really.
I do look at, Vaynerchuk, V as in Victor.
- I have 15 Facebook, 15 YouTube
just 'cause I really think--
- Dude, by the way, honestly
I know I've been shit
but I need a YouTube 201 class.
- I can hook you up.
- Hook me up because I'm
dying all about the pre-roll
where it's contextual
but even pre-roll in general,
like I need to get educated.
- YouTube bumper ads,
the six second unskippable,
it's true view, it's pre-roll
but the whole six second plays,
the ad six seconds
where it's true view.
- And it kills.
- Yeah, it's like a five dollar CTM,
watch the whole thing,
it's great for just frequency messaging
just like yo, fucking
Budweiser can in your face.
It's not what we want for,
we have Facebook for the
longer form, what have you.
- No I get it.
- But YouTube is killing it.
- Caleb, get your shit together,
hit up the team, what
do they need from me?
(upbeat music)
Let's go, I love you.
- [Jon] I'll update it, I'll send it over.
- Alright, 38, going up.
- [Caleb] We could move on to
the next one if you'd like.
- I'm not confused, I know
this ad is upside down
but everybody's upside down
in happiness and making money.
Swipe up and get on it rightside up.
- [Caleb] Alright, the next one
is the meeting with Dustin pre-roll.
That was the one where you told him
to DM five fuckers on Instagram
and tell them that he
wants to work for them.
- This Dustin?
- [Caleb] Yes.
- This skateboarder thing?
- [Caleb] Yep.
- Is this a pre-roll?
- This is, yes.
- Video?
Hey guys, what you're about to watch
is an impromptu sit down,
Caleb, big shout out to you
for grabbing the camera and capturing this
with Dustin on my team,
we were just doing a meet and greet,
he's been on my team for a little bit,
I just wanted to get to know him better
and we got going, we got going.
And for so many of you youngsters
this is a video
that is going to change
the outcome of your life.
Watch this.
- [Caleb] Let's do the same
thing for podcast just in case.
- Podcast, pay attention to this,
this is a sit down I had
with Dustin on my team.
- [Caleb] Okay, from the
interview with Drama,
you spoke about--
- Alright, I got to do this real quick.
Cool.
And just getting people to understand
that this is not throwaway content,
this isn't test and learn.
For example, a UFC fighter
that grew up in Montreal
when you run creative 23 pieces of content
over a four week period in Montreal
running media ads against Montreal,
it's going to work
but as you know, not even us,
nobody's producing that level of content
to fulfill the needs of
the media capabilities
that we have in a Facebook and
Instagram and Google world.
This is what the industry
will look like in seven years
in a lot more than it does today.
May not look exactly this and that
but we will absolutely go down
in history in the ad world
of like setting the tone
because the way the
internet actually works
this is a requirement,
everybody has to reframe
the way Amazon reframed the
way Walmart had to do business,
the way Netflix reframed how
ABC and NBC had to do business.
Everybody talks about change
and this at the forefront
but then when it comes,
people struggle with it and
I have empathy for that.
(upbeat music)
- I don't judge other people
and it starts with myself
and it's a very powerful thing.
Of course I judge people
but I don't judge them.
Of course, let me rephrase,
things run through my mind, opinions
but judgment is final, it's absolute
and I just think everything's
a work in progress
or moments in time
or angles or contexts.
You need to know so much more.
I just have no interest in being so wrong.
I care too much about myself
to judge other people.
You don't know me
and that means I don't know you
and so everything is within context,
everybody's so absolute.
The world is gray.
Let's move.
♪ I don't want to be rude ♪
♪ But I don't give a
damn about you, one bit ♪
♪ And I think you used to have it all ♪
♪ Funny how the tables turn around ♪
♪ Take it from a young
age, I know your point ♪
♪ Can't believe I made it with the music ♪
♪ Try to think about me all the time ♪
♪ But I think I'm drowning in this solo ♪
- They said Common was in
town for a free concert,
I said, "Oh, this is Gary Vee,
"oh I'm picking up."
- I appreciate it.
We're gonna go in this way?
- [Female] Yes, we're
gonna go straight back.
- I'm so stoked.
- Thank you, my guy.
- I'll see you in December hopefully.
- Looking forward to it.
- How are you?
Do you need me to get miked?
Do you need anything from me?
- [Female] We are getting
miked, we are getting ready.
- And if you need anything, they got you.
- I'm good, I'll take
whatever it is, it is.
And so I'm done with this.
When I'm done with that, I'm done?
- Then we're done.
- Okay, awesome.
Thank you.
- Okay, we have to do one picture.
- You got it.
- Yeah, yeah, I got you.
- No, no come on.
- Oh you want me in it?
- Yes.
- I know what to do.
Oh you got it?
- I got it, I got the long arm.
- I mean literally every
single entrepreneur I know
has somebody filming them.
D-Rock's a fucking noun.
He's like a term.
People are like, hi,
I'm Craig, I'm a D-Rock.
("On My Way" by Reo Cragun)
- So you have a 20 minute block?
There's no countdown timer.
- No problem.
But how will I know 'cause
I'll be in the zone?
- I'm gonna break your zone.
- I love it.
Will you be out there to
wave, get my attention?
That's awesome.
- We're sitting here editing the vlog
and this next section
is gonna be really heady
but I think it shows
kind of how Gary talks
about how he will listen really well
if it's a subject that he doesn't know.
So you don't hear him talking a lot
but I think this is really interesting.
Let me know what you think.
- So the camera of our research
was that we took particle physics,
the principles of causality and locality
which allowed Dr. Okazaki
to discover the (mumbles)
and we translated it to the brain.
And now when we looked at
artificial intelligence,
we wanted to see how
can we adapt the process
that deviates from the realm
of sensory and motor output
but rather has the
conscious aspect of things?
Consciousness is a force
that allows us to adapt.
It allows us to take the sensory inputs
and our predictions from the past
and test whether that
prediction was successful
given the audit you were provided.
If it was successful,
we reconsolidate it as a
memory in the neocortex.
If it failed, however, we dismantle it
and we build something that's--
- It's context.
- That is contextual consciousness.
It is what the eye is
fundamentally missing.
- 100%.
- And adaptability cannot be hardwired
and we can only understand that
in a process of rhythms
because even electrical
cables firing off and on
generate a rhythm in tandem.
It's such an interesting collaboration.
I'm humbled that you
guys are even listening
but I truly believe it
will change the world.
- Yeah tell me, that's what
I was about to ask you,
how does it, in your point of view,
what are the chess moves
in the evolution of this?
For me, when we mapped our DNA,
even how did operations
happen 300 years ago,
I think back to context,
humans are unbelievably bad
at understanding things
in 50 or 100 year windows.
Like when I hear you go through that,
obviously a lot of things go over my head
'cause it's not what I understand.
What I know for facts, facts
is we know dick shit about the brain,
the brain's the fucking
game, it's the game.
And so for me, I think about, it's funny,
the word privilege is very
much in culture today,
I'm actually getting goosebumps,
to me mental privilege trumps everything.
To me, that's, what's up my guy?
- [Male] That's so dope.
- Right, it's so real.
When people are like, what do I mean?
My ultimate privilege,
my ultimate privilege is
not that I'm a white male
or that I had good parents,
my ultimate privilege
is that it's real quiet
and calm and delicious in my fucking dome
and I think that when
people look at privilege
they see what the exterior is.
So whether it's this or that,
whatever it may be, whatever it may be,
but it's so misleading to
actually what this game's about.
And so when I hear that,
though way up here for me
intellectually in the details,
at it's most macro, once
this thing gets cracked,
you can get into a very interesting place.
I get that.
- [Male] Definitely wanted
to have a great conversation.
- How are you?
Such a pleasure, Gary Vaynerchuk.
Yeah man, real pleasure.
Thank you, thank you,
my man, real pleasure.
(upbeat music)
I believe the reason that most people
that actually have the steak,
AKA the skill,
don't get discovered
is because they don't know
how to get discovered.
The reality is going to
LA and being discovered
is a very 1987 point of view
in a world where
producing the content here
in a YouTube or Instagram
or Facebook world
is a far more likely way to be discovered.
And so I think it comes down
to perseverance and distribution.
- In your opinion, what needs to happen
for mass adoption to happen with crypto?
- It's just a matter of time.
In 1996, I thought by the year 2000
everybody would buy all
their wine on the internet.
It's just a shocking lack of patience.
If your thoughtful about
block chain and currencies,
you'll actually understand
that it's not in Russia,
America or China's interest
for this to play out
and I think people are naive
in thinking that those three entities
are gonna give this thing up so easily.
And so my bigger thing
is if you really understand block chain,
fuck bitcoin for a minute
or crypto, even currency,
if you actually understand
the foundational aspects
of a decentralized world,
you're gonna have to convince me
why China, America and Russia
are gonna sign off on that.
So I think that the
macro political climate
is a tremendous indicator of
why crypto and block chain
have a big fight ahead of them.
(audience cheering)
Thank you so much, thanks for having me.
So I've been spending
the last couple of hours
meeting a bunch of people here
and it really allowed
me to kind of frame up
where I wanted to go with my talk
and I think the word that's
most populated to my mind,
- Great, let's get your ears off.
- Right from the beginning,
you're always the hustle,
hustle guy, right?
But lately you've been into the virtues
and as I've heard you say before,
a lot of these cats are into
tactics and that quick stuff.
So if you were to rate those two things,
tactics and media strategy
versus the core stuff,
how would you do it?
- I'm a big believer in both.
I can have a great mental thesis
that doing push ups is gonna help me
but if I don't do them,
look, if I had to choose it,
I always think that strategy and mindset
is gonna be the trump card
because that is basically
dictating a lot of your actions.
The problem is so many people stop there.
What's happening is they're insecure
and they just want to
keep feeding the brain.
They don't want to do
'cause they're worried about judgment.
They both fucking matter.
This is the reason so many,
I'm unbelievably socially liberal
but the vulnerability is it's ideological
and you sit in a fucking
ivory tower and you don't do.
It's easy to tweet, me too.
Are you doing anything about it?
So it's really important,
they both matter.
- So believe and execute.
- 100%.
I think about life like a bridge,
you've got to be pulling,
a lot of people are like,
Gary Vee, you're a contradiction.
I'm like, exactly.
You got to be pulling from
opposite directions, right,
clouds and dirt.
You got to have bravado
and goals and aim but,
the reason so many people like me
is 'cause I'm never gonna
lose touch to that place.
- You're the man, thanks boss.
- How do you make it on
the internet I'm this age?
- I'll explain.
Okay, I think the biggest
thing you have to do
is you have to deploy patience,
it's not gonna happen overnight.
- Right, that's what I learned from you.
- I fucking put out content
for eight and a half years
before anybody gave a fuck.
- And you have to dream.
- You have to dream
but you have to execute
and that's just gonna take you time.
Either at 15, you're gonna
make it up and try to front
which is your vulnerability
or you'll just put in the
work, put in the work,
put in the work and that's it.
It's just a process man, life is long.
Just put out the work, put out the work,
don't bullshit, bullshit is
the absolute vulnerability.
- I kind of like love
everything about your
voice and what you say.
- Thank you, my guy,
thank you so much.
- You're so straight forward
man.
So it kept me in my seat,
I was just telling them,
bro, you're so down to freaking Earth
and that really is amazing.
- Thank you, my dude,
thank you for saying that.
I really appreciate it.
- I love what you have to say
and never keep mincing
your words and stuff,
it's an inspiration to
me just to be out front.
- Thank you so much bro.
Thank you for the love, that's very sweet,
nice to meet you man,
patience bro, patience.
I would literally give
up everything I have,
up everything I have
to be 15 years old.
- We were just saying that.
- I would literally give
up everything I have.
Understand what the fuck that means.
("Ballin So Important" by Villa)
(group applauding)
- My entire belief
that so much of our
shortcomings in society
is that we didn't pay the piper in 2009.
If you ask me, name one core
reason suicide rates are up,
we didn't pay the price in 2009.
I'm just a believer in checks and balances
and because we have massive
entitlement and overcoddling
predicated on not having
the proper adversity
based on our actions.
Parents today want to blame social media
and other things of that nature.
What parents aren't understanding
is we are going through the greatest era
of mass overcoddling of children,
right now, if you're a modern parent,
and this is obviously generalizations,
but the current modern parenting
is so overpredicated
on taking adversity out of the
child in the first 10 years.
We're creating zoo animals.
If you eliminate all adversity
in the first five, seven,
nine years from your children,
when they start facing adversity
at 12, 13, 15 'cause you
can't overcoddle everything,
they're completely and
utterly not prepared for it
and so you want to give your
kid an eighth place trophy
because you want him or her
to feel good about themselves,
that's fine.
The problem is that
maps zero to real life.
When you thought you were
a winner your whole life
'cause you always got a trophy
even though you fucking sucked,
you're not doing any good.
And I think that if parents
actually were worried
about getting jobs in 2010,
'11, '12, '13, '14 and '15
and putting food on the table,
they wouldn't have worried
about little Ricky in kindergarten
getting picked on and went
to the principal's office
13 days in a row.
And I really genuinely believe in what I,
and I know that that is a pretty macro,
I'm not unaware that that's
a pretty lofty thesis.
I just know my truth, I believe it,
I don't know what else to say.
- [Male] Hey Gary, you have
11 PM jet and it's 10:57.
- So I should leave.
Thank you guys
and if you guys need anybody
to talk to somebody next year
and cosign and say it was a good event,
I would be happy to get on the phone.
I mean that.
- Get a quick picture?
- Yeah, of course.
And by the way, statute
of limitation's over
but I think I bought
liquor from your store
when I was underage.
- I love that.
- I grew up in Jersey.
- I love that, that's amazing.
("Say It Ain't So" by Reo Cragun)
♪ Stay out my way, I'm on my way ♪
♪ Hard work gonna pay off, I'm on my way ♪